a thief robbed a convenience store with
watermelon on their head
as a disguise that's such a white thing
to do
i know where you're going though
i think i should just actually get one
oh yeah
you know i could i could
i could i could do uh lasso last sewing
yeah i don't know if you seem like a
lasso guy
maybe molasses
[Laughter]
it's a little more seemed like something
you'd be into
wait what it's called lat last one yeah
where you catch the little thing
yeah yeah i could do it last lasso
skateboard yeah i did it on my
skateboard yeah last was something small
i could see you last sealing up
something real small
you know like a little maybe a skunk a
skunk okay
lasso raccoons yeah yeah possums yeah
i do yeah i get all the roading small
game yeah small game small game
small gang road and gang yeah that small
game rogers game bro yeah i can see you
lasso and all of that yeah you see
last one a couple of cinnabuns cinnabons
oh yeah like dessert
yeah roping up a little bit of dessert i
could see you freaking
you know cornering a tiramisu somewhere
in a dark alley
okay i don't know why i'd be in a dark
alley but i guess why not you know
yeah why not bro live a little bit damn
i know
even in your dream even in your dreams
you're just sitting at a table yeah
don't relax at yourself and your dreams
either though yeah get out there i could
see you laughing a couple of kids
stealing some stuff at
tropic thunder oh yeah i'm like the guy
that look at it
on a hot topic i called it tropic
thunder oh hot dog hot topic
laughing at some kids at hot topics snot
topic dude it's a bunch of kids in here
that are complete [ __ ]
some kid in there drinking out of a lava
lamp yeah a little bastard stealing some
[ __ ] magnets
yeah some rick and morty magnets yeah
hey dad i'm gay
and his dad's like back off the lava
all the girls like trying to look like
[ __ ] what's her name uh who's the
girl with the green hair
miley cyrus nah they don't wanna look
like miley cyrus they want to look like
oh billy alice
billy island that's the one they want to
look like now all them kids
all them kids she always wears baggy
clothes behind them hush puppies
oh yeah hush puppies talking about them
sweater
sweater sweaty headies sweaty hitties
you think yeah oh them things
them thank thanks somebody's got them
she might
she does yeah is she of age though
brother i think named grover or
something what's his name venus
phineas mm-hmm billy from
huh here l.a from the valley
i think 818 till i die oh yeah
shouts out billy irish pirate what's her
last name pirate
uh her middle name is pirate apparently
billy pirate eilish
oh she's a real deal damn real deal
she's 18 guys
she's 18. okay let's lower her roll yeah
well it might be legal in nashville dude
you're acting all
different i am
dude i've been training bro that might
be what's different about me man you
have been training
michael chandler's gym dude and it's
different in training mma
in uh and down in tennessee is different
man how's that
oh those razzles oh they'll have you out
there wrestling a big uh
you know uh one of those big swamp boars
you know
big pig or something out there they put
they put you in that ghee now them
they're boys friendly too they toss you
around a little bit they'll throw you
around i got a couple of bruised ribs
right now
tough lady got me oh a tough lady yeah
there we go old lady oh they got a lady
out there he's got six feet man
and she and she puts it on your husband
prince on you dude
yeah big jean big jean the blue belt
she'll put this one lady put my penis in
a kimura bruh
oh damn i'm not playing dude did you tap
huh yeah
oh yeah get out of here
hopefully she's armbar in that dick
yeah dude you left late you've changed
bro you and nashville getting all weird
weird what are you talking about i got
two fractured ribs from a strawberry
thing about marrying this buckle buddy
i'm like dude you need to chill out bro
you need to get back to l.a
then buckle bunnies man you got buckle
bunnies bro
dude this lady yeah man definitely spin
a lot what did i spend my time doing man
just driving up and down the hills man
looking for trouble mostly
did you find it um i found a little bit
you know what do you do what's going on
in nashville usually i drive down to the
gas station at night
you know okay i'll go in there mill
around
try to wrangle up a couple lot lizards
yeah there was there wasn't a lot
it was uh was there a lot it was just
one lizard yeah no females out there
what was i doing
just nothing really just chilling yeah
like going to the gas station
is are things shut down there like it is
l.a no things are open
so oh you can go to the gym i mean you
can go to mma you can go to the gym
you got mask on people have mass like
when they're you know
saying hey to each other then everybody
takes their mass off something like can
you believe this [ __ ]
that's how that's hilarious that's how
it is but there is the mask on for the
beginning part
yeah you know you don't want to alert
people but once you're in the club you
take that [ __ ] i'll take it off
what else that's how leon bridges
perform one night dude i saw that i saw
that in your story
he's great i don't know who he is it was
really awesome i think you would like
him dude i feel like i'd fit right in
nashville i've been really into
yellowstone
really right yeah that's my [ __ ] you
gotta move to nashville you get in there
man what's up dog
you [ __ ] get you need to probably get
some better recipes probably
a lot of your recipes your house are
kind of latino
you're right you need to get some
southern you think you're gonna stay
down there what are you thinking dog you
don't know i don't know
i mean there's just the one what is what
are some things that i like about it i
like uh
just kind of driving around
no traffic no traffic i respect it
there's no traffic
what else you could drive out into the
countryside kind of you know
yeah i i do notice there's more time in
the day it's easier to get places so you
go do this you go do that and it's still
only 5 pm you're like what do i do now
yeah it still sounds like you're not
doing anything though
without traveling anything like that
it's been too hot oh too hot it just
started getting a little chilly there so
uh
drive that hatty bees i haven't done it
nick you were out there though you tried
the hattie bees i did i i think i agree
with you a little over overrated right
sorry hatties it was good huh the best
hot chicken i had there was at a place
called
uh uh party foul
and we went for brunch and they we got
uh hot chicken benedict
oh yeah yeah that sounds good it was
incredible i like hearties
yeah okay yeah you like hardy's better
dude howland ray shits on hattie bees
helen ray's out here dog made by them
koreans is that really cat
no it's chinese china it's in chinatown
it's made by white people
oh you guys look a little different than
the last time i saw you though
we look better right huh we look better
than we do on tv
you've been watching us on tv i've seen
some of you guys episodes
cat looks nice you two you two still
look questionable
yeah yeah yeah i respect it off camera
puts on 20 pounds
yeah what's this uh this was everybody's
been watching it while theo's been in
nashville including this family they
said
their little girl they're trying to
teach her to walk she's close and
she stood up when she heard a familiar
song
oh my god
[Music]
she said they said this was the first
time she stood up on her own that's so
cool
look at her there you go
shorty thick huh
she getting up man yeah she might be on
some cough syrup bro
damn baby it's thick she's gonna be on
some codeine out there oh yeah she's
turning
oh damn uh she's so cute she's beautiful
man
we're gonna get picked up by netflix
very good she is beautiful
uh yeah what have you guys been doing
same [ __ ] man we're in l.a locked down
dog
locked live in this communist los
angeles district
you think you all extract you're in
nashville cause you escape dog you think
you're better than us because
because you got out bro you see more
free
yeah you're living that life
[Laughter]
man did you yeah
yeah it was a tough workout man i was
kicking [ __ ] and i i never kicked before
oh you know you kick and then a lot of
punching
dog i'm about to move out to nashville
with you i'm about to get a rant are you
yeah
are you really good on the ramp yeah
we're gonna brand each other like
yellowstone
oh is that what they do yep dude you
would be good on a ranch man oh yeah why
don't you have a ranch
let's get one doing nashville open up
our own comedy scene out there doug
yeah get a little stage on the uh kind
of out on the ponderosa i guess or
something why not man yeah mix it up
i got up on stage again at uh zany's
yeah so that was cool how did it feel it
was scary man
but did you do a full hour no 15
hot 15 yeah wednesday night i got a
regular set this wednesday
yeah so this will already be you you
guys will have missed it when you're
here in this episode but
yeah i'm trying to think of what else
has been happening man not much
i hurt those ribs pretty bad man that
ribs are bad when you hurt your ribs
it's
the worst that's what i want to what big
[ __ ] sat on your ribs
listen hey you [ __ ] with theo i'm gonna
roll up what jim is it that's michael
chandler's gym man chandler listen i'm
gonna roll up and twist some [ __ ]
heads off dude you guys keep hurting
theo damn
especially hey big jean what's up [ __ ]
make me a 300.
maybe a 300 big jean bro
i felt like she ate them she freaking
tore them out there's some baby backs
and then some big fella slammed me too
yeah i realize you can't fight the big
guys man these guys
you can if you if they know what they're
doing what's that big dude's name man
don't make i'mma could be in nashville
in november timmy i think her big tommy
tell big time number up then slap his
ass around and he's missing a grill
piece too i will say this
in one tooth he misses you should have
learned the first time he's missing one
of the better better teeth as well you
know sometimes you can miss one yeah
he's missing one of the money makers
something like that yeah yeah you know
but i should have known better man but i
got out there and he really shook me
damn god it hurts man shouts out to you
damn that cat's in the wild yeah
gracious cats in the wild brendan
let's get into it dude let's jump right
in
brendan also got in the ring while theo
was in nashville it's nashville
that looks like nashville what was that
nick
so that was brendan cats of the wild
someone saw chappelle
[Laughter]
being broke so many times
i'm saying it's my fault
damn i'm done i'm throwing my hair out
like that
it was dope i gotta do
[Applause]
that looks like the same wig snoop dogg
had in baby boy
i haven't seen that shout out to rallo
blast yeah shout out to rollo
great singing by the way rollo bro you
think you're better than us because you
got out
i'm not
[Laughter]
i thought we stepped the budget up it's
a hologram dude i don't know what it's
like over there there i am right there
they found me and rogan fighting i guess
[Laughter]
rogan's actually an unlockable character
but someone created theo oh yeah that's
hilarious
dang dog and you were you were crying uh
online like a buckle bunny about dust
and pouring making more money
oh dude they gotta pay him uh they pay
by tony ferguson
anybody dude every these guys out there
you know giving out they're giving it
all
you know they giving it all dude some of
these guys they got to rearrange their
face to even smile
yeah you know to even whistle yeah it's
a [ __ ] and here i am telling to pay to
man right here
the diamond don't want to take the fight
that he don't want the fight man y'all
know good him that man never turned down
nothing give me your hair looking chris
man never turned down a fight
you got uh that boy will
go outside in december with wet hair
just to fight a damn cold
man that's facts and y'all need to pay
that man dana
you'll need to split that bag up and pay
that man dana pay that man
hey man yeah that nose is flared up dog
oh because i got slammed by a woman dude
i got slammed right on the beak bro a
couple times
getting beat up huh it's hard out there
man how many you're gonna do
three days a week three days a week damn
i had to take a week off though bro they
bad i mean they banged me up man the
ribs yeah you come in there you the new
guy
yeah like let's beat this f and they
call me the f word call me the n word
somebody did it oh damn
they said let's beat the la out of them
yeah let's beat this guy huh let's beat
this little
s-p-i-c they call me let's beat this
little guy
damn beat this [ __ ] little bunny
[ __ ] yeah this little
japanese [ __ ] somebody oh wow
what the hell's a buckle bunny a buckle
bunny yeah that's like uh
you know how they have like uh like lot
lizard for truck drivers yeah it's them
hoes
buckle bunny are like hoes for the rodeo
no is there a name for all groups of
hosts according to brennan there
is uh another reason i want to start a
ranch
yeah oh yeah right dude i can't believe
halloween's coming up though huh
dude we did the halloween special last
year remember
yeah you and i dressed as a toy story
yeah
buzz lightyears i still got the costumes
yeah you can't do the same thing twice
yeah what will we be this year
that's a good question maybe people
could send in ideas we could be be of
some butthead
oh i love that you get some choices and
a vote and you guys should have shown my
shit's growing back
out dog damn huh come back out it's
crazy you'll get it cut in a week
no i'm not doing it really i'm not kind
of dang
i'm not trying how long are you going to
grow it as long as theos there we go
dang i respect i'm trying to grow mine
as long as cats
so oh my ex-boyfriend used to have
longer hair than me no
way yeah that's not good got this
was a bit of a problem was it yeah
because we'd sleep and then like i'd
roll over on his hair i wouldn't know if
it's my hair or not
oh yeah it's just i'd like to have the
lady problem so if you don't want to go
in the shower and see hair i
don't know if it's mine and he has
conditioner and [ __ ] yeah
and then when you guys are wrestling
naked you know i'm talking about when if
he's on top his hair's all in your hair
oh if his bun comes out it's a problem
like well he has pushed in a ponytail
it's always in a ponytail that's not
sexy what age do you think people stop
having sex
you think how old are we whatever age
that is i'm four
seventy seven do you think no no no
doctor jubilee busting nuts he's seven
he's not seventy but
i'm talking 50 maybe you think 50 yeah
yeah if you're having sex past 50 that's
insane
yeah addiction yeah doctors do you say
that sex at least three times a week
which is also very bizarre crazy how
many blew my mind
he said three times a week at 62 years
old i'm down dr drew he probably he's
probably just real healthy
yeah but even if i'm real healthy the
last thing i want to do is be having sex
i'd rather be outdoors doing something
maybe grilling out wrestling
yeah wrestling just slammed by big jeans
it's hearty over there man dog you know
what gets me excited
i know what it is baby that meat on my
grill
i'm talking box them cuts them rumps
them shanks
all that meat yeah when i was young my
mom dated a meat man
oh yeah and every now and then i'd know
if he'd been over at the house that i'd
wake up and there'd be a fresh thing of
bacon at the bottom of the steps
well your mom don't have to do that
anymore because we're talking about
butcher box man
quality meat quality matters yep times
change no longer does your mother have
to lay out a little bit of leg
to get a little bit of shank you know
what i'm saying no more summer dresses
for that meat box
not everyone has a convenient access to
high quality meat we'll take it out now
because there's butcher box man
butcher box believes everybody deserves
high quality
sourced meat every month butcher box
ships a curated selection of high
quality meats
right to your crib man but your box is a
no-brainer it's the best meat in the
world shipped right to your door
which means one less trip to the grocery
store yeah it used to be you if you
didn't have any meat you're like oh i
will ever get meat well i guess i'm just
vegan now yeah unless i'm you know i'm
i'm trying to sleep and i'm counting
sheep and when them gets hurt and lands
in my bed you know we
grill it up yup not anymore but now it's
changed you get two pounds of ground
beef in every box
for the life of your subscription dude
you talking about the highest quality
meat around for just six bucks
a meal and right now king of steam you
guys get butcher boxes offering new
members ground beef ready
fo life yep don't be a butch go to
butcherbox.com
k-a-t-s that's butcherbox.com
cats get that meat deal look man
what's up man i'm feeling dang fast
today
i'm not dude i'm on this diet i'm not
getting enough greens
i'm exhausted
you got something maybe a powder i can
just make some water and get all my
greens
yeah man i got that green machine for
you that athletic greens
the easy all in uno
solution to help your body meet its
nutritional needs
are you talking about 75 vitamins and
minerals but old days you had to get
over the sink you had to have a couple
carrots
couple beets do a thing of lettuce do a
thing of romaine
right an ear of cauliflower do a tomato
take you an hour and a half and you
barely you ha
you just got a salad well i need to
increase my energy i need more focus i
need a clearer mind bro
lift your body lift your life get
yourself together
on this green magic dust get
green right now man so whether you're
looking to boost energy support your
immune system
hit them with that dirty deal oh how
about that gut health let me give you a
deal you filthy animals
i'm talking about all you got to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
kats claim this special offer you
receive
a free d3k2 wellness bundle with your
first purchase
that's up to one year's supply of
vitamin d as the added value when you
try their delicious comprehensive daily
all-in-one drink
you'll be hard-pressed to find a more
comprehensive nutritional bundle
anywhere that's right it's
athleticgreens.com k-a-t-s
go get on it get green it is cool though
the only thing that stinks is that ghee
when you put it in your car and leave it
in there for a day oh
so holy [ __ ] you gotta air that thing
out dog dude it is
and then you don't are you the stinky
guy in a g yeah
is it g or g d it is but i call it g
yeah dude i might that g stinks dog
here's a
oh damn here's matt peter guy yeah
that is mad brenda with the quickness
i'll get a picture of matt barnes as we
play his question thank you sir
yo what's up guys my name is aaron i'm
from connecticut
sure really what's in connecticut i mean
we got a bunch of dunkin donuts
yeah amen and a couple of a couple of
native american
casinos but yeah espn dog you know
bristol other than that there's really
nothing much but anyways i got a
i can't understand it for you guys and
it's got to do with getting down and
dirty
uh just you know it's a preference you
know some people prefer to have the
lights on
so that they could see you know the
operating procedure
and some people just like taking shots
in the dark if you feel what i'm saying
so i mean i gotta ask you guys what do
you guys prefer
lights on or lights off wax song wax off
in gang buzz buzz i'll see you guys
young gang gang
young matt barnes yeah man um what do
you think chappelle
are you a sexual man dim the lights oh
dim them
them the lights get that r b going oh
you know
all she sees is them teeth yeah exactly
she spells teeth she's like where are
you at and i smile
i'm right here girl whisper in your hair
what's up girl what's that cheshire cat
yeah yeah you rang
that's right all your girl hairs is two
days gonna be the day
that's what i do i pick up the guitar
before i get going you know two days
start playing a little song yep that's a
good question i'm trying to think of
what i like man
uh sometimes you just catch yourself in
the mirror with the lights on like god
dawg i need to get my ass on the
treadmill yeah so that can be kind of
inspirational
um i go lights on especially with a
baddie
yeah i go lights well otherwise you
could have sex with anybody if the
lights are off who gives a [ __ ]
i go little lights on so i can see what
i'm messing with
i don't know i go maybe a lamp on or
something maybe a candle in the distance
there you go
yeah i don't want a porno set yeah i
don't need great stage lighting like
it's a goddamn podcast
you know what i'm saying somewhat girl
let me set this up yeah hold on girl let
me get this [ __ ] podcast like nick
let me borrow
what about you uh chan let's go let's
get some info i'll tell you right now
let me answer for you right yeah
yeah true but he wants to see you take
his underwear off you know yeah i'll
respect that however
i like morning too we do morning so the
light's always on no matter what
sex in the morning yeah and then it's
lighter insane
jesse james that's insane
lights off at night for sure in the
morning huh hey and the morning's tight
yeah right i don't like how chin said
we'd do it in the morning that made me
feel weird
and you're late for work
[Laughter]
you picked your way to start your day
though it's the best way
all day long that's the best way to wake
up i think if you're a man that you get
all tired then you got to go to work and
do some xeroxing or whatever
or construction yeah or construction or
something man i'm tired you know what
i'm saying like if you're wrestling big
gene all [ __ ] night
you want to go home and then you know
put in more cardio
you got the bruised ribs i'm erect right
now dude honestly are you
no damn bro you have to think about a
dog i know when i'm a wreck you idiot
you gotta know bro you gotta get your
first thank you a morning bird
uh yeah cause i'm usually tired at night
and then you you sleep it off you're
re-energized in the morning you work all
day go back to bed rinse repeat yeah
that's fair you guys are ill
you changed man brenda's right he
different different
got that nashville swag better than that
because you made it out yeah i think you
made it out because you don't have these
state taxes
you think you're better than us look i'm
just telling y'all what it's like over
there man there's no
just buffets everywhere unlimited food
yeah nice
oh yeah people are nice and you never
run out of gas
oh okay you could drive forever man good
food
people are friendly yeah and it's just
man everywhere you go it's like
somebody's like hey come on over here
buddy have this have you want some
mashed potatoes you want some diamonds
you want some diamonds yeah anything you
want man people
it's like north korea oh it's crazy over
here i'm trying to smuggle out dogs
smuggle me back in your briefcase
i don't know man that's a lot to smuggle
yeah that ain't smuggling when it's that
big
you know ship me to nashville i'll beat
the [ __ ] out of big gene dog
damn boy we got 300 big ass jeans
dude it would take gina freaking two
months to get to 300. yeah
i'm just saying man i'm dang erect right
now
so you've changed what did it though cat
talking about in the morning
no i don't know i mean yes with matt
barnes
i would be the only i can't admit
anything else in here did it
i'm not going to say any men man you
can't say chin going we do it in the
morning
that made me sick i don't know i think
maybe just talking about it or something
did you sense that we were gonna about
to play race my case
no i didn't oh that's we haven't done
this on a hot segment yeah that does
give me a lilly wreck i know yeah
chill out though yeah and i feel weird
all right the first case an online store
owner traveled
530 miles to beat up a female customer
who made a complaint about late delivery
the online shopper was beaten into a
concussion by the merchant the seller
traveled a day and night
from east to uh to the south to seek
revenge he showed up a week later to
attack the customer before giving her at
the close
attacker has been giving a 10-day
detention and his online store was
suspended oh not bad
we got white white dude has that just
that fire inside to travel through the
night get there and beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody
i don't know it sounds very mercenary i
don't know what mercenary is but
it sounds very like um
i'm gonna say asian wow
he said well chin's offended yeah
i'm gonna say asian chin you know i just
immediately saw a black person
i just that's just what i saw okay you
can say it that's fine
okay racist but that's no no i'm just
kidding
chappelle uh i'm gonna say white i don't
think black
i don't think a black person is gonna
spend all that energy it's a lot of work
that's a lot of work
yeah you know when you can just press
the issue on site like right there
then it's fine but to travel that far i
agree with theo i see like an asian man
beating a white woman for some reason
yeah that's fair because if it's a white
guy or white girl they just try and get
them canceled on social media
they wouldn't drive by a fair point cat
and theo got it right
but we're gonna ask you guys get more
specific oh
kind of asian i'm gonna say korean
i don't agree with it i agree korea yep
i'm gonna go korean as well you got that
han
it was a chinese guy oh [ __ ] dude
and we do fake news nick
we do a video of the attack oh
oh it's an asian woman oh it's in china
this makes perfect sense
that makes sense oh whoa whoa whoa
nobody told me these are international
stories i would have said chinese all
day
oh he can't tell you that dang he robbed
her
he did quite the combo yeah oh never
mind he
waited about me i thought i was about my
store and this is in another country
nick yeah this is china wow
i didn't know where you're going to
international waters we have we have
that's crazy
i thought it was always america r.i.p
man okay
so uh we'll say one one tie between cat
and theo or you got two all right all
right all right
uh we had
a thief robbed a convenience store with
watermelon on their head
as a disguise that's such a white thing
to do
i know where you're going if it's on the
head
it's dicey where you're going i'm not
glad anyways
[Music]
a lot of diversity dude we all
are full there's a moment where we all
fall victim man uh
i'm gonna go with urban gentlemen i'm
gonna go with white
that's someone who's everybody said said
theirs chin uh
watermelon on the head i would have to
say white just like scenes
that's why cat cat uh i'm gonna shake it
up and say
something latino oh can i change mine to
black
yes it was a
white guy wow wow [ __ ]
and that is cultural appropriation also
i want to go out and say that
that's the widest part about this crime
yeah yes
did he get canceled for it oh out of
masks robbers wore watermelons
let's see a uh a guy stole lottery
tickets and then try to cash them
at the same store dumbass
so they put a watermelon on his head no
this is different oh
oh god so wait what happened yeah what
happened with the other one uh
they got caught with the watermelon on
their head and stealing stuff
sounds like you don't know but go on
they found them i
don't know sure we didn't have a picture
of them though
let's see a uh police arrested a man who
stole
uh scratch-off tickets from a
convenience store and then went to the
same store
to try to cash them for just over a
hundred dollars
black with the cop trying to catch on no
no the
the they caught the guy trying to catch
him black
and he did it hours apart first he
cashed the 30 that he stole then a
couple hours later i would say black
black yeah you think so what makes you
say that chappelle what makes you think
that
yeah we don't have lots of justified
really but by people like lottery
tickets yeah
it's the scratch scratch-offs the
scratches they're doing that for ages
yeah she's been doing that for a minute
older generations like them too i think
i'll go black bingo is more of a white
thing right
i'll go black i think so scratch off
more black actually you know what i'm
going white
i'm going black black cat same black
latino he was black
wow man you should have stayed
that's crazy to do to do it at one place
and then come right back and try to cash
them you're just so brazen
stupid unless he has dementia like maybe
he's unwell
yeah probably oops we can't give him the
benefit of the doubt man
probably and we got a picture of him
i don't know if it's ad block or this i
swear if it's my dad
[Laughter]
oh there's no black in that picture he
does not look like he has dementia
though
you don't think so he could he has
something else i just don't think it's
dementia
yeah some problems it's a gambling
problem for sure
yeah whoo man if you want it i got it
that's what i tell people
you want it i got it i said look you
want it i got it
dog it's the holiday season so if you're
gonna be shipping stuff you better do it
correct you better be using
ship station will be ringing the ringing
dog fastest easiest most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders
just a few clicks you're imagining yours
printing out
shipping labels your products out fast
when i was young it was different you
had to be outside you went outside at
the end of the driveway and they'd have
a little pony or something come by a man
with a pony
and you tired you tie your package onto
the pony oh hopefully get this to
somebody a few weeks hopefully it gets
there not anymore ship station helps
online sellers
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs keep customers happy
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website
stations they know all dog they know no
wonder the number one choice of online
sellers and right now
king of the sting listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days and use the
offer code k-a-t-s hit him with that
deal fat patrick
patrick yeah sorry fun fat patrick
you're spongebob
okay all right you got that square body
anyway click on the microphone
top of the home page and type in k-a-t-s
that's shipstation.com
enter the code k-a-t-s shipstation.com
make
ship happen fp slangin deals
oh and we had one more cats in the wild
actually that just uh popped up
oh my god oh my god that could be
useful dang that could be
what you playing bro that could be you
dog
you know how big i have to get it yeah
yeah you're on your way
meet yourself at 340. dog meet me at
three six
he's got the uh i mean i don't know if
that's malibu rum shirt but
is that marcellus wiley uh no it's a
marcellus wiley posted on his
because people he people were getting
tagged as like marcellus in the wild i
guess
but it it was chappelle on essence
magazine which is
uh black women's lifestyle guide black
love and beauty
it says big men's fashion damn yeah
that's that thick
fashion i need i need to recreate that
photo yeah
do you think you should yeah yeah that
should be dope it looks like a breakfast
shirt
yeah you could be on there chappelle
because i got the gold chain and i got
the shirt
i just don't have those shorts i don't
have them khaki shorts that boy got them
big
tits yeah right it's a big tits
that man's got some damn tits on there
yeah i got the skin tone
do we we guys very similar yeah you have
to shave your head though i don't know i
don't know if i want to do that you
could take your hair off with uh
in post yeah that's true and we got one
more
how about that boy got a cannon you
think i'm gonna need some khakis
everybody has a little bit of something
a little bit of this today that's that
big grouper
he's already got tiny feet yeah he might
have that small wiener dog
big balls small wiener crazy
you don't have that big boy big dick
energy with your shirt popping like that
your tits out like that that's that rick
ross
i agree with you theo god is fair
there's something wrong bbsw dog i'm
talking big balls small wiener
you got a camera big ball small it
happens every day
if you look it up i can't look it up on
my my computer has blockers on it but
[Music]
bbsw dude it's a group it's a real thing
yeah
it's uh big bone women yeah big balls
small
big bone women that's bb w and here's b
b
b s w yeah big ball small wiener yeah
big ball small wiener
and it's very it's uh people it's kind
of like the new thing
because uh big bbw's either big bone
women or big black woman
is it no you get both big beautiful
women yeah that's what i thought i
thought it was a big beautiful woman
when i was younger i wanted to get my
nuts
taken off farmer when i was younger it
would just be all penis
because imagine that you tell a girl no
nuts all penis i'd be like they would
try it
you know oh that's fine some kid yeah
but
also some teens do that after
transitioning oh i wouldn't be doing
that
he said he's keeping the wiener yeah i'd
be offering that getting rid of the
purse
yeah it's almost like when they came out
with uh what's the candy one of them has
nuts and one of them doesn't which one
oh my god home enjoying mounds yeah
sometimes like a nut
sometimes don't you don't oh it says
nuts
still don't yeah
yeah just tell a girl hey could you
imagine all penis no nuts
yeah yeah have you had it yeah have you
had it have you tried it yeah
maybe you should be an almond joy for
halloween that's not a bad idea
that's not about it i don't know it
racially it wouldn't go over well
oh that's good because you have to pay
himself in chocolate
[Laughter]
yeah and then i would have to do it too
you know
well i got to be a candy bar too we
can't be two chocolate dudes
up here yeah i mean you could put this i
think
we could probably cover we could cover
ourselves in chocolate if we went out
with chappelle i think we could i think
you can't just do it by yourself
you walk if you walk out with me i think
you're good i'm chappelle lacy and i
approve this message
yeah okay and put some like peanuts like
going around your body
i don't think so do your chocolate face
huh your chocolate face chocolate body
look at this leave the face uh them
outfits
y'all gay duh that is the whitest outfit
i've
ever been i'm disappointed in the white
culture [ __ ]
man [ __ ] dude that [ __ ] pisses me off
bro hold on
look up also okay
[Laughter]
y'all got to see this picture if you're
listening on the audio yeah that's the
worst picture you've ever [ __ ] seen
i got nuts i don't
who's mounts and who's all the joy
between you two i got the nuts
yeah i'll go no nuts man oh i ain't
going chocolate face though man
no almonds all joy
look up worst uh black cop do each
ethnicity and look up worst whatever
halloween costumes
because that's our first asian one that
has to be the worst
white costume i've ever seen that's one
of the worst white ones ever yeah
when you're you and your wife dress like
a something and it's
sad yeah it's more sad
what else you got are we looking of
we're looking for pictures of asians in
bad costumes yeah dog
gotcha
and there's that baby right there
dressed like a carrot
that's bobby lee on the far right
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god it's so cute dang
dang oh and all getting traffic too
that's the saddest part i wouldn't do
anything for halloween
it's um it's far what are you what are
you gonna do and it's cove at times it's
the year's been scary enough i feel like
but that is definitely better oh my gosh
look at that bobby has those glasses
yeah
annie has that inability to act like an
adult
dang bruh [ __ ] yeah halloween yeah what
are you gonna do for halloween
yeah so far out i don't know what i'm
doing next week oh yeah that's true i
forget it so far i'd like to think of
everything always in it
like early i respect it thanks man
what i'm not doing is going chocolate
face though okay
hey live a little dude you're not gonna
here's the thing you're not gonna do
blackface once your whole life
act like you ain't done it all right
really maybe i don't know how you guys
doing i've never done it i don't
we don't play that [ __ ] dog dude we're
freaking tough in nashville dude
at the mma gym dude they have us
fighting animals
fighting scarecrows that have them wild
pigs yeah
fighting all kind of stuff danger danger
sounds like you're just fighting big
jeans she's beating your ass
what have you got nick this is a king or
stinging
brandon ain't so les schwab theo
the lot king lizard got the king getter
sting it for you
state fairs you about it you ain't about
it
gang bangs butt plugs
all right and this is recent in utah
okay yeah you talked
yeah we were in youtube they don't give
a [ __ ] about mass corona nothing
so i love affair me too nothing man you
get that big old prehistoric turkey leg
yeah little funnel cake i love it man
the rides a bunch of vomit [ __ ] i don't
like the rides
you don't i don't like we're scary what
i don't i don't like the ride
dude i don't know what not back flips 30
in a row but you can't go on the damn
zipper yeah i'm in control over that i'm
not in control of that damn zipper
yeah you can't go on the [ __ ] ferris
wheel but you do 17 backflips
this is the one we went on that
everybody would vomit on oh gosh
i don't like the rides either though i
cried out you been on that theo
constant vomit dude oh god i vomited out
of every car
have you been on that one where the the
slingshot like they sling shot you up
what fear are you going to you talking
about six flags we're talking about
county fairs yeah we're talking about
neighborhood pull
you know the rides are gas powered we're
talking yeah
they go bungee jumping at the state fair
bro the gravitron used to get on that
and the guy that had a guy on there
would show everybody his wiener while it
was going around
you couldn't do anything you were just
like
look at this dick
back up the wall and then you got to the
bottom and you couldn't even look around
and see if anybody else saw his penis
face is
blue oh your face is like this yeah
so you got to the end and you're like oh
i guess i'm the only person that saw it
even though everybody saw it
damn that's aggressive it's sexual
harassment yeah but it was like as a
group kind of it was like
you're impressed together yeah it was
basically the lazy sues in of [ __ ]
being visually molested
yeah really i don't know if they have
that right anymore though
the zipper the zipper or the or the one
where it
spins real fast oh the gravitron it was
called do i see gravitron inside
what it's like inside of gravitron we
had a ride at uh
elitch's in denver called the rainbow
and
it would kind of do the same thing but
then some poor kid here we go
no this is here we go i couldn't do it
puke get your cups
this shit's fun though and you can't you
try to move your arm it snaps it back
because you're going so fast
oh gosh you can't even get a boner in
these things chappelle
well no it's very hard too but what you
could do is if you had a little date or
some girl you was interested in
you could try to set your hand on her
yeah and she couldn't get it off yeah
once you what you're there you're there
dog
[Music]
i mean look at this people are just
absolutely miserable this is
diesel-powered
that's diesel there's always that one
guy who tries to lay the other way
opposite
ah dummies some guy wants to do that
they
are who's the dj in the middle oh perv
wait you really can't move at all oh my
gosh it's so fun
that's pervy johansson in the middle
dude you'll get sick though
you'll get what sick oh i thought you
said something else dude because
that guy by us was showing what you did
too
the guy bus was showing peen back in the
day yeah that would make me puke
oh those are fun too yeah [ __ ] i get
elves
man well g up bro yeah dog take some
[ __ ] uh
i have half a red drama yeah what it
does right yeah
have half a red bull man or something i
can't i can't do it look at that ride
huh
damn that gravy on that [ __ ] burning
will get on that rod right there
oh yeah i'll ride that thing all night
what's that that's just ice cream
blueberries the food there's nice too
i am damn she's scared another thing i
miss about the fair
yep the animal area oh my favorite the
goats
you can grab the goats whatever you want
oh yeah you could touch all kind of
animal
texas texas has a really great state
fair oh i've been to that one
a lot of places do man it's a nice place
to walk around the kids everybody's
walking around
calabasas is a good one they do oh they
do for halloween they have like this
state fair halloween all the food trucks
come it's dope oh
i love a good food truck me too
young man man state fair 69
king it yeah because why would you sting
them who doesn't like them
like why even if you don't like the
rides you can still do other [ __ ] yo you
ever gone to a flea market
i might have it's dicey i've been to
some shady places
flea market and super shady really
you're the kind of guy that would go
you're the kind of guy that well i feel
like we'd go to a flea market and like
hate everything
no i loved it really yeah i grew up in
flea markets dog
oh really yeah oh i didn't see that on
your on the tfa-tq website bio
that's not mentioning your credits when
you come to the stage i know right yeah
you know this guy from his flea market
childhood
okay that sounds
made up dude no the flea market in
denver is lit bro
oh flea market brendan want me kind of a
little more hoodie like there's just a
bunch of weird
[ __ ] it's people are selling whatever
they want oh they roll their vans up
they're selling trinkets out the back
there's funnel cakes i used to get a
looney tuned shirt
had criss-cross on it you remember the
crisscross the group
it would be like bugs bunny and
tasmanian devil and they had the
clothes would be backwards hell yeah one
of the baseball cards
one of the biggest flea markets is at
the pasadena at the rose bowl every year
it's a good time one of the issues i
have with it is most of the stuff they
sell in everybody's selling it
yep come over here and they gotta uh
they'll have [ __ ]
yeah we got a um taxidermied
dorito or something and everybody will
have it yeah as soon as this man's got
it this man's got it well now but back
in the day everything was original
yeah more original stuff yeah come over
here and get this two thousand bottle
caps
six dollars damn it's basically it's
basically like a pawn shop
yeah but for air buddy for everybody and
it's outside now i've gotten some good
asian trinkets out there i've gotten
some good asian woodwork
you'll see a lot of good chinese
woodwork out there did you haggle with
them
yeah i'll haggle with them are you good
at haggling i like it
i feel like asian people haggling is
just them yelling at you
oh really yeah this guy this was a white
guy
selling asian stuff so maybe he knew
like asian people that had died i feel
like you'd go to flea market and buy
fishing gear i well the closest thing i
went to is a
which is a swap meet and i did pomona
santana
or costa mesa and i always buy fishing
gear i'd buy remote control car stuff
and i would buy um
you know survival knives yeah we opened
the back of it you have like
fishing wire i mean fishing like you
were single for a long time
survival knives
remote control claws brendan survival's
important
it is doug it is you think you think
chin shouldn't survive
no he should they look a little tiny
string saw
well who's doing that look chen i'll
support you
this shit's getting weird dude yeah i
told you yeah okay
this tiny string saw yeah like two
little rings and it's metal and you
would do like this
so it cuts the wood
just
it was awesome who's this little buckle
bunny
she's got a kinder stinger too oh
what up theo what up brennan coming to
you from kolkaska michigan and i got a
king intersting it for you like the nose
piercing
personalized masks don't touch me
but keep touching me gang gang buzz buzz
love it yeah it's awesome i didn't know
we made those yeah
do we make those she made it oh type
move that's
duh yeah sell them girl big bang girl uh
yeah put them online if you want i don't
like mass period but i guess if you're
going to wear
one i'll tell you the stupidest [ __ ] is
people that have the mask that look like
their teeth or their
lips that's just stupid really yeah
i feel like that's the best case
scenario because then you're at least
getting some idea what they look like
i saw a girl on the plane the other day
and i wanted to talk to her
but i didn't know fully what she looked
like
there's nothing in masks everybody looks
hot to me all the girl all girls are
caught in masks
oh that's true yeah damn she's a bad he
takes the massive like holy [ __ ]
everyone looks like sexy ninjas in masks
yeah that's maybe it's just a fetish i
have
i don't know all right good for you
as a dude as a dude you just gotta wear
the band bandana like you're a bandito
yeah that shit's dope now you have a
reason to wear a bandana no one can say
[ __ ] you look fly
no [ __ ] or blood is gonna come up to you
here's this guy right here he's been
obviously
drinking marijuana
[Laughter]
culture corner chin nick hayden fellas
down here in uh melbourne australia
we've been locked down for
quite a while now stage four we can't do
[ __ ]
we can't go more than five kilometers
away from our house
how many stages is this this is my
brother
obviously that means why is the lip so i
swallowed a haircut so
i haven't had a haircut in about six
months and i just wanted to know
dudes with ponytails king of the stain
gang gang buzz cuts he looks like
everybody from this podcast in one
he looks like the person market version
of all of us
brandon is a beautiful young man that's
what i'm saying
from another country that's for you nick
i think
you know how hard it is to grow up in
another country i say it looks like my
brother is a handsome dude
he is a subtle hell he's a setup
he's on brothers your brother has a
grateful dead tattoo on his chest
easy easy easy
grateful brett over there
dude this guy uh set a lips on him
but also you know kat
said this man she doesn't dig guys with
long hair
yeah um long to a certain extent like
the
late 90s like kind of shaggy longer here
on dude that's fine if it's longer than
mine i'm kind of like hmm if you're not
jason mamoa i'm not here
see i i'd like mine get long enough put
in a man bun that should be dope i'm
getting there i'm close
you were close and then you got it cut
for some weird reason i freaked out dude
yeah that's why yeah you're right cat
broke the news on uh our new cats after
dark that she's single
we lost all our patreon subscribers or
you're not single anymore no i'm still
single
oh okay you're dating someone yeah but
that's not different from
fair enough
your date zone on the regular cat yeah
what
yeah who is this lucky gentleman huh uh
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] who is this young
gentleman look at it nick
said he would go check the equipment
i look over there because like this
she's like so [ __ ] up guys
the [ __ ] cameras are off hold on cat
talks quiet
[ __ ] uh what happened guys i met him
through mutual friends that's it
wow white guy
[Laughter]
they should have family feud in his
ph.a.m and it's just
oh that could be so good the weirdest
vietnamese game show
that's hilarious i got no guesses it's
vietnamese even white people just trying
to
kind of figure out each other
[Laughter]
chin freaking nose dude you [ __ ] in
the dark weirdo
yeah dude the only thing that [ __ ] in
the dark are [ __ ]
dolphins dude you're out of your mind
man
unbelievable unreal nick
let's see we got
i wanted to know what you guys think of
our new the new sidekick on this past
weekend
uh this is so this is a submission for
me it's king
i love this kid so i want to show him to
the world king it or sting it
riley here's a little bit of riley you
have a lot of body hair
rally i don't i would have guessed that
man honestly
really yeah did you have any birth
defects or anything like that
um i mean i'm a musician like i said but
know when you were born were you missing
anything did you give any birth defects
he's booming with personalities
it's uh spanish for
in in indiana are you good at charades
no not at all i always wanted to smoke
crack honestly
have you had a high drug experience
raleigh i've not i mean you know i'm a
christian eagle scout so i'm like the
eagle scout
people probably ever meet you know in
bali they have so many monkeys that a
lot of them have gone into bad ones they
put them into detention centers you
support that kind of thing
yeah i support all monkeys whether
they're that or not cause asians you
can't i mean you take a razor to an
asian you'll barely end up with a damn
sideburn on the ground they're not
they're not hairy people
are they are the yokozuna's hairy i
don't think so
he's not giving you a lot to work with
though he's not giving you a lot to work
with he's a calm fellow man
cool as a cucumber baby he's a person of
color man i'm trying to
trying to help him out yeah i see what
you're doing i'm very progressive of you
man he's a young fella and we met him
off the internet
[Laughter]
you know so we'll see how it works
that's how they meet people now the
internet
and here's a girl right here you seem
like a nice girl hi everyone at king and
the sting my name is ashley i'm from
maine
theo i can't believe i missed you at the
airport if i knew you were there
i would probably bring a banner for you
and divorce papers for my husband
okay just kidding my question is
primarily for brendan but i would love
everybody to weigh in
my son recently told me he wants to stop
playing soccer he has
four years he's 13 now that means he's
easy and dive back
into the world of jujitsu mma
all of that he wants to be a
professional fighter
um i'm terrified because of you know the
risks and i know there are risks with
every sport but i am
i'm terrified brendan risks shaub over
here
for me how to best kind of get over that
and
how to support him because i do want to
support him
thank you so much gang gang buzz buzz
buzz buzz young lady well my first
advice keep them away from big gene
yeah right now number one nashville
powerhouse
[Laughter]
uh your kid wants to remember he's 13.
if it's his passion i'd say let him run
with it but it's a tough go
it's a tough go you know how long did
you train brendan before you started
fighting
uh i was training for probably three
years and then i was
off to the races wow damn within a year
i was fighting golden gloves
and i was entering jiu jitsu
competitions and then the ultimate
fighter came who's golden glove is a
black guy it sounds like it but it's a
it's a national boxing tournament
turn up and i only had six months of
training in boxing and they put me in
that tournament
i didn't even know they said golden
gloves is next week i went i don't give
a [ __ ]
well we signed you up like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy that's my first competition
and i won it you did yep all knockouts
damn dude it's so violent brenden it was
a curse
why are we so violent yeah what do you
get at the end of the tournament what do
you guys get out of this
sweet belt i got this big ass belt are
you so happy
oh yeah well my dad has it hell yeah
dang you didn't even get to keep it
no damn oh uh but if your kid's into it
listen as long as your kid's passion
about something but fighting's a tough
go man but i think he'll learn quick
whether or not he's into it for the
fighting or if he just likes the
training part of it
like you never know what's going to lead
to yeah also the chance him
sticking with it being a professional is
not good so who knows what think about
it no kid wants to do karate anymore
no they see the jiu jitsu 100 kid wants
to do
plus he might make some friends make him
tough probably give him some confidence
riley mao actually is a taekwondo black
belt back
who like mel who the young fella from
nashville yeah the guy that was just
well tell them talk with your chest dog
you a black belt [ __ ] speaking
of all scared and [ __ ] is riley mao big
jean
yeah you should bring him to jiu jitsu
with you good correlation cat uh
i don't know you should let big jean get
a hold of him
big jeans ruthless dude big genie it's
all ruthless man
it's the ruthless it's danger bro but
yeah i think it's i mean i think it's
it's neat for kids i think i don't want
my kids to do it but really
no not at all if i would have gotten
into when i was young i think it would
have helped me with a lot of confidence
big difference though if if they want to
do jiu jitsu or wrestling
go full go but if they want to do like
boxing and
mma and get hit in the head no yeah got
it
it's risky risky that'd be my
fighting name steal risky vaughn ooh
i like that like that has a link to it
what does that even mean
all right dude that could be your
country name too in nashville
risky vulnerable risky zombies oh you
see risky vaughn
yeah i'm already have theo von and
they're already getting tickets to that
no you'll sell more if it's risky bonds
risk getting a bad name dude that's a
great nickname
risky biscuit risky vaughn yep risky
vaughn
the life in time
damn man yeah i definitely miss you guys
man i know
man i gotta hit me up all the time i
know i got back to my apartment it was
just like
i have no friends left really nope not
one
not one my kid just hitting him up
harassing him
yeah dad back home you got to be a dad
now again
yeah your kid's like [ __ ] my dad's home
this is a nightmare mom this is a
nightmare like i know
i know his friends are gone
you got me here dawg love it man i'll be
out in nashville i'll be out there in
november and then
oh yeah that's right if you want to do
dog you're moving out there i wouldn't
you know
don't make me jump across don't twist my
arm now like big gene i'll come out
there
dude i'll take you i'll take you on some
tours out there it's definitely i mean
who's out there now josh wolfe he's
gonna move out there
who uh there's someone else moving out
there too oh miley cyrus but we don't
know her
i think she lives there now yeah i think
she lives there now
ben shapiro's there ben shapiro's moving
there not my friend don't care
um oh justin timberlake good buddy
he's always in there i think he's from
there yeah he's original
yeah he's from knoxville maybe
oh will compton's out there will compton
good friend of mine
yeah i don't really have that many
friends out there maybe my friend neil
my friend tim get lonely
yeah it's a little bit like eight
o'clock at night it's like all right
what do i do
i can't get the tvs to work at the place
i'm staying either so that's the worst
so you just been on your cell phone you
had to be on my computer or my cell
phone
you know i got an indoor washing machine
that's not good
mm-hmm it's pretty cool and it's a stack
one you can wash your property out
there's not bad
probably out there no state tax either
yeah no state tax
so that kind of stuff is good i mean i
don't know the place is cool i probably
can just use some more fixing up would
you move out there came out and saw it
you'd move out there oh would i move out
there yeah i'm down to
experience anyplace else there's nothing
really like keeping here
wherever you can gamble hey wherever i
can gamble and
podcast dude i will say this i made
probably
1200 on nick's picks last week did you
oh wow because i had a bad week
bad decision
it depends i don't know i had i had a
couple wins but like i lost that
kevin holland decision oh yeah i didn't
pick that one the ipoke and the nico
price fight [ __ ] me
really but those are freak accents yeah
i know so it's like long run still gonna
win but it sucks saturday
damn patriots [ __ ] me last night and
last night nick was on a
six-game parlay all he needed did you
see the end of the patriots game
yes he needed cam newton to get in the
end zone
two thousand off a hundred dollars six
six games
damn it was rough chin i feel like you'd
fit in nashville
of course paint me a birmingham yeah
i would actually there's little bars and
clubs you could just perform open mic oh
yeah i could do that
if they don't kick me out why would they
kick you out because i'm
different yeah but
they're not racist at all right there
dude as long as you're not black you're
fine
yeah you're good oh i thought oh okay i
thought it was true
like everybody's just like yeah yeah go
white face yeah
go white face for a little while wear a
cowboy hat white face i can't go my face
but something's gonna give it away
you get a white face dude my face looks
wider than all of you guys they're like
that guy's creepy looking
like yeah your face is wider than that
why are you talking about everyone's
here who's this tall hottie man
[Laughter]
nashville is a liberal city man the the
state is kind of conservative i think
overall but the
i mean if you look at things
specifically like that but
i don't know that state right uh i'm not
sure
the city i know is is pretty clay travis
is out there
my boy yep out kick is out there i mean
it's
it's what is it like i mean right now
it's still a little like
you know not everybody's there so all
the schools probably i guess maybe
they're back in business
some are some are you know when you
first flew out there your first night
did you think you made a mistake
no the first night i i just got in so
late
i was i think i was pretty excited
that's good you know
the hardest part is just like thinking
about like what's it gonna be like
you know podcasting from there um and
then deciding like i decided like when i
go back next week i gotta make the place
i'm staying more like my home i gotta
like
try and you know get a wall art or get a
something you know a rug or something
and then eventually if you decide you
want to stay there you have to get a
real place you know they don't have to
get a real place yeah yeah
but i know you can definitely get nicer
places for you know the money
and then also there if i wanted to buy
like a studio building it's like
okay you could probably get this
building for 200 grand
or 300 grand whereas here it's gonna
cost you then you might have a friend
who would go in on it with you know two
million
yep yeah yeah you might be able to find
a friend that would go in on it
i feel like there's a lot of like
possibility there kind of
so that part's kind of exciting people
are great i'm not gonna make any
decision until six months i'm gonna wait
six months
yeah because everything could change
wait six months there's definitely like
i got back yesterday i went to the beach
and i was like god this is so
this is nice it was nice to be at the
beach there's good things about la
there's terrible things about l.a i'm
gonna give it six months before i make
it
you know what's illegal in nashville or
just tennessee is kratom
so that'll be a tough one damn
else you can't even get it smuggle that
[ __ ]
is it a dangerous drug no but i mean
it's
vilified in the media so oh yeah
but it's not bad i mean i've been doing
it for four years
yeah you seem right yeah you're a nice
guy yeah you have sex in the morning
with the lights out
[Laughter]
it can it can't be dangerous for some
people i'm guessing if they get addicted
so
be careful don't do it i use that [ __ ]
look at that
how do you take it pill form but you
know what the promise is my third
podcast of the day and i've taken every
podcast
i find it if if you take too much then
you know how i was like oh it's like
tropics under i can't remember certain
things
it it'll trip you up like your brain
like
overloads and then it's like i create
them right now oh yeah like
every day i can remember and nicotine
and caffeine i can't remember billy
eilish
like i can't remember uh hot topic yeah
i like how out of all those things billy
eilish is what i think it's just
you though brandon no usually i'm not
you with the references i'm usually
pretty good but yeah
if you're using that barnes well that's
easy but if you're using kratom this
long it'll ca it'll trip up there's
something with that like
when i do stand up i don't do as much
kratom yeah because if i have
back-to-back shows and you gotta do an
hour stand up i don't do as much
because if i do that second show the
words i'll start flipping some words
brain fog yeah right yeah yep i forget
stuff too so
that's probably one drawback what's the
better good yeah what is the benefit
if it just for me it feels nice and it
feels like
like a little bit of kick like coffee
but then relax yeah that makes any sense
yeah the benefits i like to get high
nick
i'm out oh yeah i like drugs dog yeah i
can relate to that getting that up right
i like the little high like nicotine i
like whiskey
all right sometimes we eat a butter
right out the package [ __ ] yeah
you ever seen that movie limitless you
ever seen limitless it's like that
i want to watch that again it's good huh
yeah it's all right
i haven't seen a long time my watch
tonight
there you go well if you move to
nashville we'll ship you some which
leads us to
uh we want to do so uh we want all
submissions from delivery drivers out on
your routes
uh good stories king interesting it's
debate clubs
uh we got a lot of delivery drivers now
ups fedex what can brown yeah for you
usps the originals
are we only talking about the postal
system or are we talking about delivery
like postmates
yeah amazon po i like postman
delivering auto parts let's get the uber
[ __ ] up there man they're dropping
humans off yeah original human
trafficking yeah yeah
yeah if you think about it
i'm in dallas next week on the road dog
you are dallas thursday friday saturday
addison improv should help be there yeah
i'll be there and then then i'm in
nashville in november gang man
that's dope dude what to do you know
what i'm saying when i get there don't
don't be like i'm going to show you
around there bro
all right oh my god i didn't say
anything
don't have big gene pick me up from the
air
you bring this up she'll pick up on her
back bro
she's tough dude i'll be in new jersey
um
uh the first weekend of october actually
are you brave got two nights over to one
show
one night two shows we're out saturday i
don't know they're outdoors
they're outdoors over there so outdoor
shows i think it might even be sold out
but i don't know
but it's tickets on theovan.com get em i
got dates
oh you got tampa coming up right
chapelle headline tampa
are you really through 18th yeah yeah
come on say hi tim dillon's going to be
down there too i know he's
he's just picking some dates down there
people hitting the road man
let's get back to normal people are
hitting the road yeah i've been hitting
the road but i feel you and i also got
covered but you know what i'm saying
but we don't talk about that yeah i'm
stronger we needed it to happen to you
first yeah
i was the guinea pig i was the canary
yeah i came back coughing
amen
good stuff all right let me do this
oh sorry dude that's all right brendan
and theo fighter and weight i got to go
in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso in the case of
ritos but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do
theo looking like not type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
oh yeah
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you